travel feels a bit more complicated
you're not alone some coveted error
restrictions have changed and it can be
hard to know what the rules are right
now we connect with an expert for a
quick round up of where things stand and
how to plan for the next several weeks
masks are no longer required on domestic
flights but some airports are still
requiring them if you're going to jfk
laguardia or lax for now they're still
upholding those mandates for those who
prefer to wear a mask you're still
welcome to do so specialist luzon smith
with scott's chief flight says his team
members observed a third to half of the
passengers masked on flights during the
past week
for international flights mass may be
required depending on the rules of the
destination the best way to get clarity
check the website at the airports you're
traveling through contact the airline if
you're not sure and it's a good idea to
travel with an extra mask or two just in
case now when it comes to test taking
the united states is one of the few
countries requiring a negative coveted
test to enter even if you're fully
vaccinated if you are going abroad and
then coming back just be mindful that a
day before that departure that you make
sure that you have a negative test the
issue that some people are facing is
that they you know they forget about
this and they end up stranded in a
foreign country because they don't have
a negative test so it's something you
really want to make sure that you're
remembering before you come back to the
states and finally many flights are
still changeable for free all airlines
are still waiving change fees for any
ticket above basic economy so that's
kind of the trade-off you get with that
basic economy price you don't get the
flexibility of the other tickets
if you have a trip book that you know
you don't want to take or you can't
don't cancel it he says and take the
credit right away because if the airline
cancels it or significantly changes the
schedule you're entitled to a cash
refund